kanye west shocking revelations the
moments he says led to his nervous
breakdown
we know Kanye loves to speak his mind
and ever since he popped back up on her
Twitter feeds it's like a third of the
internet wants to shut him up another
third is praising him and that last
third either doesn't care or they're
super confused by his latest rants well
buckle up because today
Kanye appeared on TMZ live and revealed
he got addicted to opioid medication he
was taking after liposuction he went on
to say he got hooked on the drugs during
the st. Pablo tour and this all led up
to his breakdown in November 2016 which
kept him in the hospital for over a week
and forced him to cancel the rest of the
tour I was drugged out I was on opioids
two days after I got off of opioids and
I was addicted to opioids two days I got
off of opioids um I'm in the hospital
now in another wild interview he sheds
more light on that nervous breakdown and
even takes on Taylor Swift again and
Beyonce in a nearly two-hour long
interview Kanye tells Charlamagne tha
God from the iHeartRadio is the
Breakfast Club that he thinks fear
stress being in control and manipulation
all led to his hospitalization part of
that stress he says was his wife Kim
Kardashian's Paris robbery competition
and the fact that the tracks off his
life of Pablo album weren't getting a
lot of radio play they put that same
amount if not more work into a piece of
work and then you used to it coming out
by graduation where everything is
everywhere you know it's frustrating and
really ever since the Taylor Swift
moment it just had never had never been
the same connection with radio it's like
whatever powers that be it was much
harder after that Kanye blames the drama
over his song famous for not getting on
the radio as much and apparently that
was just one of the many factors that
led to the breakdown which he referred
to as a breakthrough for now the rapper
says he's in a stronger place but Taylor
isn't the only relationship he gets
candid about in the interview Kanye
talks about his falling out with jay-z
he even calls out Jay and Beyonce for
not making it to his wedding to Kim
Kardashian in 2014 you know I gotta say
you know I was hurt about I was heard
about them not coming to the wedding
I understand they was going through some
things but if his family you know you're
not gonna miss a wedding you know and
I'm not I'm not using this interview to
put any negative things but I got a
statement present it
yeah I got a state my truth
[Music]